みなさんこんにちはわー
木村周一郎です a
僕はですねー
昭和44年4月にですね生まれまして
そして昭和50年
に幼稚舎から慶應に入りました
で歩2分
塾講 de 大学大学は法学部の法律学科
はですねあのー
入って平成3年に卒業して
生命保険会社に入りまし
でその後あの世界に入っていくんですけれども
まあ
普通部からですねええ
始まりましてこの学校っていうのは非常に常に
落第と思う
あの
恐怖に晒されながらですね内部進学者は
暮らしていくわけですね
まあ
僕の場合は本当にですねー
及第点スペースデー
もうすでにていく飛行だけど落ちないん
グライダーみたいの生活したんですね
ですからだいたい僕よりも上にいると落ちないん
みんなのことだと思います
ところが僕よりも下にいるどあやばいぞと
冊なようなあの
学生生活でした
ですからね大学時代はあの幼稚舎生にスキーをしていることをずっとやっていました
ですから11月半ば
もう
この辺りからですか a
雪
の上にん
経ちましてだいたい帰ってくるのが
5月もん
いたけど
その間試験を受けに会社にあるパー会社の奴学校に帰って
で履修後とって又雪が開くと
そんな生活をしてました
ところがですねあのー
今回
そんな中でですねあの知っておいて頂きたいことが1校ありまして
その当時
運動部のスター選手たち
この人たちが今5分なっても50近いおじさんなんですけれども
その50近いおじさんになったとき
スター選手なんだろうか
実はそうでもないんですね
で
僕なんかはそのパッとしない学生だったのが今こうやって話しをしている
これがですねあの
人生の恐ろしいと思いますね5
チェーン水っていうのは花が咲くか分からない
だから
そのためのみんな準備をししててくださいっていうことを
特にその
企業の学生の形にはお話ししたいなと思って
できましたん
ですねあの
まあ
ひと言で言うと生きる力これをつけておいてほしいなということです
でまず
会社に就職します僕の場合は
当時この場合はバブルの絶頂期に言いましたのでだいたい
入りたい会社に入れたんです
ところがまーじーずうまくいかないもので
先輩に
ちょっとちょっとって言って言われて行ってみると
ドカ下げてこの会社入るんだろうなっていう
動かされてその会社の生命保険会社があります
生命保険会社入ったときもどんな会社か分からずに入っちゃうんですけれども
6年間うまく
方針営業という仕事をやりきって
そして a パンの境界に入りますこれがだいたい1997年の話です
で
当時ですねあのー
パン屋さんのパン業界の柱人たち
おじさまたちがですねあの
食事しながらお酒も入りながらお話をしてるんです
どんな話ししているかと言うとお店知らない人に
パンについての自分たち彼が考え
つく中での1番も
教育を施したらどんなパン屋作るか見てみたいねという話をしてたらしいんです
でそういう話をしている時にたまたま僕がですねこのパンの強化に入るという噂が入り
まして
a さっき話があったように私の実家はの日本で一番古いアイヤー
ですのでそうすると
血統書で言ったら
一番いい血統書を持っているのが全くパの触らないでよくここまで生きてきてくれたと
いう
じゃあ
じゃあこれをですね題材にしてじゃあ一つ
最高のそのパンのカリキュラムを作ってみようということになったんです
まずはその横浜のパン屋さんで
ベーシックなパンを触って
そして職人としての心構えをまず
付けて売っ
そしてアメリカで製パン理論勉強してニューヨークのパン屋さんで
ニューヨークで一番評価が硬かったパン屋さんで
やっぱり今度
作りそしてへ
やはりありですねフランスの最高峰のその
今日一番の強豪地区の一番評価の高いところで
技術を磨いて日本に帰ってくる
いうカリキュラムでした
まぁ最初大変でしたあの
まあ皆さんご存知のように
慶應義塾っていうのはですね
お坊ちゃま学校のようで
非常に高勝率の厳しい学校なんですね
ですから先輩から言われたことは
何でも大概のことははいですね
そうやって暮らしてきました社会に出てもまあほぼ一緒です20代の頃は先輩に言わ
れると
あっ
例えば
空を切って歌いと言われたら
歌いたくなくてもはいなということをもうよく止めされるわけです
そうやってやってくると年上の人が言うことを聞いてないんだといいのかなと思ってた
んですけれども実はパイアの世界に入ってみると
僕の上司に付いた人っていうのは最初の先輩が9歳年下だったんです
山大変でしたも
9歳年下の人に追い回されるわけですが入ってください
天パーなってきてください
さらってください
行きはれるわけですところがですねあの
まあ教わる以上は
マーチャント
しついていかなきゃいけない
んですよね
ところが
を創案負ければ頭先なくてもいいのかな
と一瞬思ったんですけど教わらないとそっから先いけない
なんで僕は
その人を抜いちゃうことにしたんです
もともと僕はもう27歳でパンの業界入りましたから
バイヤーとしてのデビューがとっても遅いです
例えば普通パン屋さんになるのっていうのはだいたい高校を卒業したりとか
中学卒業したりとかライ氏は遅い人でもサイモン学校卒業してパンの職人さんになるん
ですけど僕の場合は4台に出ちゃいましたし
サラリーマンも6年間やっちゃった
とっても出だしが長女です
でその人そんな人がですねこれからパン屋さんのお店の主になっていくっていうことを
考えていくと
もう1-5倍
10倍のスピードで
仕事を覚えて身につけていかないとなれない
ということは
やっぱりその
9歳年下だろうと元年早くやってようとその人の入っていかないと
はっ短期間で1兆倍になっていることができないわけです
のそこらへんからですねあの僕のパン作りっていうのが
どんどんどんどんその
下克上の世界に
テーマが下克上だったんです一個上の人をやっつけ
追い抜かして次の人を見つけてその人をやっつけてその1やっつけて言っているうちに
あの
メゾンカイザーがある人
そしてこうやってお話できるようになってきまし
今度はのアメリカに行くんです
アメリカに行くとその間舌というところで
安の基礎理論勉強することになります
パンっていうのは実は発酵食品なので基礎理論勉強するというものは実は発酵学を勉強
するということとほぼ一緒でした
ですから1化け学を勉強するんです
ところがですね僕はの
大学で何やってました
法律だったんですね
入った会社生命保険会社
まったく理系と縁のない会社なんですね
これがいきなり基礎化計画アメリカで英語でやりましょうな男子になるともう
う着者になるわけです
例えば正会頭アメリカの学校っていうあの
入っちゃった人のため new バック発見用のテストというのがあるんです
これがですねこれをやっていくと
をものの見事にバカなくに使うわけです例えば僕の場合
じゃあ簡単な試験で o 2って何ですか酸素
英語で書くと大キシーちゃんが今度はわかるわけです
水江膣をかけます
英語でボートかけます
co2に参加かの素中でもかけんちゃんこなろうと思った時にですね
た
鉛筆が止まるわけです英語でだけない
これ結構大変なんですはい
ちょっと勉強すればまぁ買うもん対応記載ことが好
わかるんですけれども襲っからもスタッフでした
またですねあのそういうそれくらいの言葉にハンディキャップ抱えてアメリカへ行って
しまうと
なかなか友達を作ったりとかそういう快挙になじんでいくってことがとっても難しいん
です
で
僕の場合はですね
溜まったら必殺技が1個あったんです
諸先輩たち期待ていただいただけで
酒がやったら強いん
[音楽]
たとえばアメリカで
こんなことがあったらその子が28歳の誕生日になりました
その時にクラスメートがみんな僕の誕生日をお祝いしてくれる
近くのバーでみんな集まりました
28歳の誕生日だからすって
28番にでキーな桜
ショット現元のうんです
その結果
僕のいた町ちっちゃい街だったんですが2番今5000人の街かな
だいたい僕のことを知っちゃいましたうん
しかも町で字がつくんですちょっとん
そうするとですね例えば道路でどっちが先にそんなきゃいけない
なんだかんだと揉めてもですねだいたい僕が持っているとあちょっとなんだけど ok
ok ですよを取れるようになっちゃうんです
で今度だいたいそこの研究者に行くとまぁあの英語英語デーその基礎が計画のことない
ジャパンに関する基礎ば経営学のとだいたいわかるようになります
このニューヨーク行きますニューヨークのファンや
またここはヘビースプレットてもなんですけども
何か入ってみるとですね
まあもうの見事にラテン系の人たちばっかに英語で話す人がほとんどいないっていうの
はそんな世界でした
やっと英語で喋れるようになったなぁと思ったらこんど
スペイン語の盛大に入るわけ
それこそ寒さとかエレン月から米ミュージックずーっとチンチ人掛けながら
お仕事していく
仕事があると辺にコーンが入って
を取りに行っちゃったりとかですそのそんな世界と思います
あそこの代替お酒飲んでみんな仲良くなった
フランス行きます
今度はですね
フランスに行くとですね
他の実は高校の頃第二外国語でフランス語だったんです
大学もフランス某進学資金フランス語でいきました
ところが
まずですねイミグレーションを通過した後
切符を買いに行きます
電車の
ところが
自分の今度新しく住む所の最寄り駅を知らないのに駅名知らないのに切符買えないん
ですね
自分の
行き先は館内の駅深いないもこれ日本
日本語でもわからないことフランス語でなんか絶対言えないみたいなそこからの
スタートなんですね
大ピンチでしたもうぼったくられの覚悟でその時私の運転所住所を足して
ぼったくられながらもうチームの
アパートに着いたんですがそこからのスタートです
ところがその
フランスをうまく言えないもんだから怒られても逆に怖くないんですね
ni
どんなに口汚く怒られても全然票入ってるみたいだと思うなのか
さっきからのさんでした
ところがの言葉わかんないと全部の失敗を全員が失敗の僕のせいになるんですね
そうすると多い出されちゃうんじゃないかなもうそんなところからスタート思います
今度は
頑張っている食事勅子とか飲み会についていくんですけど何言ってるかわかんないから
もう
割り勘用意みたいな感じ
いいところが徐々に徐々にわかるようになってくる
キッカケっていうのを1個ありました
実はあのやっぱりそこでも
酒飲むんです
ところがそれ飲んでいくとですねー
皆様気になってどうも僕と一緒にいると楽しくなるんじゃないかというみんなが勘違い
するんですね
実はお酒が飲んでると楽しいだけなんですけど
で
そのうちにですねもう積極的にコミュニケーションを取っていくうちに
なんだかよくわかんないけど仲良くなっちゃうそうすると今まで一番にしてきた連中に
素通りしてきた人たちが今度や
それはあの枚のせいで僕のせいじゃないなという話をですねこう
援護してくれる人たちが出て行くと
今だみんな僕と一緒に飲みすぎちゃって
仕事にならなくなっちゃう国と一緒に飲んじゃダメみたいなんですね
そそんな私が出たりしています
例えば
台湾に行くとですね
このみんなカンペ関平つ飲み干すんですね
ところがこれ飲まないでいると
胸襟を開いてない心を開いてないしってあの
信用されなくなっちゃうんです
その膝初めて台湾行った時なんてもビール中に入り
省杭州7本
おいスキー日本
全部の目をしました
でも
そんなことやってきたんですけどでも
何でしょうあの
さっきば鏡するのが良いという話をしようと思ってんじゃないんです
だ高校生たちに今から先のみなさいって言うつもりもないんです
ただそのう
何だろう自分のことを客観的にこうみて自分の武器なのは何なんだろうかということを
きちっと理解しておいてほしいなっていうのだ
1番のポイントなんです
それを分かった時に
世界中どこ行っても生き延びていく力をつけることができる
そういうことを申し上げたいなと思っておりました
ですから君のが
これからどんどん
いろんなことにチャレンジしていろんなことを知ってそしてその中で自分の中で何が
強みになっていくのか
きっとそれはかって
チャレンジしてもらったら世界中どこいっても
通用するような人たちになっていくんじゃないかなと思います
どうぞ
頑張ってくださいそれをあの我々は
裏かな応援しております頑張って下さい以上です
ん